How I'm showing up every day for those around me,
that becomes my legacy.
(bright upbeat music)
You distill Longpath down to like a sentence.
Are you doing something for the next generation or not?
For what we do or don't do in the next 10 to 15 years
will have a knock on effect for hundreds
if not thousands of years.
Let's be honest here for a second.
Can we?
We as a global society currently face a few challenges
and some of those challenges are actually existential.
They're challenges that simply cannot be solved
with the mindset, the institutions,
and the paradigms that are currently in place.
Instead, these solutions require
that we think beyond certain economic,
political and social constraints,
and actually beyond our own individual lifespans
to consider deeply the impact that we will have
on many generations into the future.
They require an applied mindset that today's guest,
Ari Wallach calls Longpath,
which is a way of being,
it's a verb that cultivates future conscious thinking
and behavior to build more hopeful visions for the future,
turn those visions into action,
and while we're at it,
build more meaning into our lives and our legacies.
Ari is a futurist although he hates that term,
he is a social system strategist.
He's also the author of a brand new book out this week
aptly-titled you might have guessed it "Longpath",
which extends a discussion that he began
with his 2017 Ted Talk entitled
Short-Termism is Killing Us: It's Time for Longpath.
This conversation asks a very simple question,
how do we become great ancestors to our future descendants?
And the answer lies in upending
our traditional thinking around the future.
It entails developing something called
transgenerational empathy,
and it involves orienting your life around
this idea of telos, a life quest that is bigger than you
that will help you make peace with death
and guard your lived experience with greater meaning,
greater purpose, and greater fulfillment.
I really enjoy talking to Ari.
I think this one just might leave you reevaluating your path
and your priorities in a positive way.
So please hit that subscribe button and enjoy me
in conversation with Ari Wallach.
Super nice to meet you.
Thanks for doing this.
My pleasure.
Excited to talk to you about all the Longpath ideas.
It's been really fun immersing myself
in your world over the last couple weeks.
But before we get into any of that,
we gotta clear up a little business around
our mutual Andrews.
Yes, sure.
So a couple weeks ago on the very same day,
I got text messages from two of my favorite Andrews,
Andrew Morgan and Andrew Huberman
both of whom have found the podcast a couple times
urging me to check you out.
And I know, I think if memory serves me,
you went to sixth grade with Andrew Huberman?
So Andrew Huberman and I go back to the sixth grade
to summer camp.
That's nuts.
So I know there's Andrew Huberman of today
as we all know him.
The explosive internet sensation,
that is Dr. Andrew Huberman.
Yes, I know him as the explosive sixth grade sensation.
Paint me the picture of a sixth grade Huberman.
Hasn't changed much.
Still an amazing mind, an amazing friend
kind of sees around corners.
In many ways some of the stuff
that we'll talk about in the book
especially on the neuroscience side,
came from my interactions with Andy.
That was an area that in some ways what's kind of,
not an area that I normally explored or was going into.
But when you have a friend like Andy Huberman,
it's kinda hard not to think
through a kind of neuroscience lens.
Andy has been there, birth to my kids,
weddings, mitzvahs.
He was just in New York for,
and I'm fortunate to have him as a friend.
So he's one of my oldest friends.
That's pretty cool.
And the other Andrew, Andrew Morgan filmmaker,
are you guys working on a project together
or what's the story there?
I'll tell you the story.
So Andrew Morgan, I have these two Andrews, right?
Young, Andrew that I've known for a very long time
and there's the new Andrew, old and new Andrews.
So Andrew Morgan--
Very different Andrews.
Very different, but still amazing human beings.
So Andrew Morgan and I met not that long ago,
I'd been working on an idea for a TV show.
And in many ways it's kind of a lead off
from what you read in the book.
I mean, there's parts of the book
that I wanted to explore even further.
And kind of the big part is,
well, what does a future look like that we want
and how do we get there, how do we back cast into it?
And so what was happening was,
as I was kind of surveying the media landscape,
looking what's out there, everything,
and I say this not as an anthropologist
or a social scientist but as a father.
Everything that I was seeing on TV
or reading the young adult section
that had to do with the future,
especially on the fiction side,
even on the non-fiction side was dystopian.
It was all about the end of the world.
It could be the hunger games or whatever it is,
it was out there.
And I realized in doing research for this book
that much like sports psychology,
and that's kinda like my background was growing up doing
sports and kind of visualization
and I was a pole vaulter.
And so I never thought to myself
while I was lying my back running through my steps,
running into the box to vault,
what does it look like for me to miss?
That's not what you visualize.
You visualize, what does it look like to stick it
and do the jump, but there was no kind of media
or content out there when it came
to thinking about the future.
There were some kind of techno solutionist stuff out there
like Gways Monorail features,
but nothing about these kind of broader, more
magnificent flourishing futures.
And so I was fortunate enough to kind of get
into a meeting with Catherine Murdoch
who had a really a background in finding a lot
of climate change, communications and research.
And we started having this conversation.
One thing led to another with her,
and then now joining us is Drake
as another executive producer.
We're creating this show called
"A Brief History of the Future"
and Andrew Morgan is our director.
Fantastic.
So is it a documentary style or narrative?
It's a little of both.
So "A Brief History of the Future"
will be a six part docu-series.
We're doing it on PBS, and I'll explain why in a second.
But basically it's kind of this on the road Bourdain
meets kinda thinking about better futures
and better tomorrow.
So what I'm doing is, I'm kind of out there meeting
the folks who either have ideas, or concepts, or prototypes.
And they could be in technology,
or it could be in regenerative agriculture,
or even in rethinking kind of criminal justice,
so prison abolition, and having conversations with them.
And then kinda we step back,
this is the cool part using VFX, or CGI,
or even watercolor, we're gonna say,
okay, what does this look like scaled out?
What does this look like in the 2030s, '40s, '50s, or '60s?
And so every episode will be kind of dealing
with these major issues of our time,
but not just saying, oh, this is a problem
and here's how you solve it.
And so here's an issue, here's a crossroads
be it technology, or obviously the persistent horizontal
that is climate change.
And then if we're going to kind of solve, or work,
or rethink it, what does that look like?
What does that look like at scale?
So every episode will have me kind of going back
and forth throughout time.
Yeah, it's very cool.
And the psychological implications of forecasting
a better future are profound because to your point,
when you look at media culture
or just contemporary culture at large
and what we consume in the context of what is gazing
into the future does tend to be dystopian.
So it's almost like this massive SIOP, right?
Like okay, well, if everything that we consume
about what our future might or could look like
is negative or dire then we all inhabit
that awareness and it doesn't give us anything to aim for.
No, look, you know negativity bias.
We're in some ways,
if we go back several 100,000 years,
we are primed at the amygdala level
and we'll get to the prefrontal cortex later.
But at the amygdala level to actually seek out things
that are bad because the things that are bad
are the things that kill you
and the one thing you wanna do is live.
And so it's not so much about having visions of things
that you want, but about having visions about the things
that you don't want.
So it makes sense in some ways that the content
that is out there is dystopian.
'Cause in some ways it's signaling saying,
hey, you don't want this.
Now we gravitate towards it
and that's the interesting market dynamic, right?
So on the one hand you wanna put it out there
and people say, oh, well, we really don't want
that world or that vision.
But then it keeps getting created
because it keeps bringing people into the theaters
and they keep buying the books.
So it's kind of this perverse incentive model.
We know we don't want it, we know it's not good for us
but we keep doing it.
Yeah, but to extend your athlete metaphor,
like as an athlete myself, you can't achieve a goal
unless you can envision it for yourself
and then work backwards from that
to create a roadmap to get there, right?
Yep.
So if all of our future casting is negative,
we're not really constructing an admirable bullseye
that we can all collectively kind of coherent around
and work towards.
Exactly.
What we are building is the anti bullseye,
which is in some ways could be in terms of maybe
social genetic fitness, a good thing,
but net, net for global civilization
and population in this year 2022, it's not a good thing.
And in the absence of that, it becomes a vacuum
that we're trying to fill with this show.
So we should start shooting that probably
in the next few months.
That's pretty cool.
So let's define our terms here for a minute.
Explain to me or to the audience what you mean
when you use the term Longpath.
What is this all about?
And then perhaps, also kind of paint a little picture
about your background and how you got interested
in this area.
So Longpath is an applied mindset, right?
So a lot of times people will say,
well, this is a solution that we need to solve this problem.
And what I've found is more often than not,
at least personally when someone comes out and says,
well, this is the solution, this is the solve,
I tend to have a reflexive like reaction to it.
The antibodies come out when someone says,
well, this is the way to do it.
I often obviously see that a lot in maybe religion,
but a lot of self-help books.
It's like, these are the 10 steps to solving your issue,
whatever issue X is.
So first and foremost, the reason it's a mindset
is because I wanted to find a way
that allow people who read the book or to practice
and be part of, kind of bringing Longpath into their life
to not feel that it was overly prescriptive, or dogmatic,
or this is the way you have to do it
to see the results that you want.
It was more like, here's how you activate
and live in this moment so that you can navigate it
in a positive sense.
So that's what Longpath is, it's a mindset.
Pure and simple.
But specifically it's a mindset to navigate this moment.
So what I talk about in the book
is that we're in this intertidal phase.
So the way to think about an intertidal,
when you go to the intertidal zone in an ocean,
obviously I use it as a metaphor,
it's that piece of land that is always either above water
or below water based on the tides.
And in the intertidal, you kind of have
both this massive chaos, it's a very disruptive zone,
but also massive creativity.
You have muscles that learn how to keep water
so they don't suffocate and all these other things.
But intertidal, in some ways kind of like an inter regnant,
what Graham, she used to talk about,
which is kind of the old ways are dying
and the new ones are yet to be born.
So I realize in the work that I've been doing
at Longpath Labs and previous work for 20 years,
that we were in this intertidal moment
as a global civilization.
And so if we want to kind of positively navigate it,
we're gonna need a mindset
that's kind of bespoke to the moment.
And so Longpath is, sure maybe 40 or 50 years ago
could have been an interesting mindset,
but I really kind of created and did the research for it
so that it could be used right now
in this intertidal moment.
So essentially it's a mindset, it's an active verb,
it's an approach to living, thinking, and problem solving
that considers not just future generations
and the implications of our actions now
on a future that has yet to be written,
but also importantly has to consider the past as well.
Like there is this, in the book,
you talk a lot about like how we can't solve these problems
and think about the future we want
without really contemplating and understanding the past
from which we come from, our ancestry.
Yeah, I mean, look, so your previous question is like,
how did I get to this?
Like how did I come to Longpath?
Everyone has an interesting story, an origin story
of how they got there.
Mine starts off, unlike most people when they talk about
their story they're like, well, I was born in this year,
in this location.
Mine starts off in the 1920s when my father is born
in a small town in Poland, kind of a schtatle if you will.
It was Poland that it's now Belarus.
And he was 17 years old when Germany invaded Poland.
And within the first seven days
he lost his two older brothers to the Russian front.
And within months, all the Jews had been kind of put
into the Jewish ghetto.
So it was him, his father, his younger brother,
mother and sister.
And within several months,
the mother and sister had been shipped off
to a forced labor camp.
We later found out they had been sent to Auschwitz.
And so who was left was my father, his brother and his dad.
And at one point the Germans as a kind of sick and twisted,
I don't know what game,
decided it'd be interesting to see what would happen
if they shot my grandfather in front of my dad,
but told my dad that if he'd lean down to help him
he'd be next.
Would he actually kind of break or not.
So awful.
And so clearly my dad didn't lean down because I'm here
but soon thereafter, he and his brother escaped the ghetto
and they joined the Jewish underground
and they joined the resistance.
So for about two and a half, three years,
he was part of the Jewish underground,
rose to become kind of a commander.
And soon after the war became a Nazi hunter
and there's a whole story there.
I mean, what a ballsy thing to do,
'cause most people would've just fled, right?
Most people would've just fled.
The story that I'm telling you is one
of the first stories I remember being told.
This is where I learned the idea of agency
and where you can actually make a difference,
even if it's small.
People often asked him, why didn't you flee?
And his reply is somewhat grim,
but it was basically like, every Nazi I can kill
is one less Nazi that can kill us.
That was it.
It was visceral and it was real
but that was his reality.
So after the war, he was arrested by the Americans
and placed into like an IDP camp
because he was smuggling Czech orphans to Palestine
or pre Israel right to the Palestinian mandate.
And they arrested him, and he is kinda given a choice,
either work with the Americans
or work with the Russians doing more intelligence work,
or basically stay in his IDP camp for who knows how long.
And what is he like?
22 or something like that at this time.
Yeah, and so what he eventually does is,
with the help of some cousins,
he escapes and that ends up becoming...
Basically, post-war Europe was a mess.
So he would go back and forth between racing motorcycles
on the Autobon and playing semi-pro soccer.
And eventually he and his brother through Portugal decide
they wanna go to America.
To him, Europe is dead, Europe is a graveyard
both of his family and everything he's ever known.
And besides America is where he wants to go,
but at the time America's not letting any Jews in.
So the only place that would let him in
in that general direction was Cuba.
So he lands in Cuba in 1952.
And soon after he's in a...
This is obviously pre Castro, Cuba.
He is in a casino and there's this old man behind him
sitting on the couches kind of whistling a tune,
but it's an old Yiddish tune from the old country.
So my dad kind of like whistles the tune with him.
The guy, oh, they start talking.
Well, that guy ends up being Meyer Lansky.
So if you know, Meyer..
Your dad's life is a movie.
This is the movie I wanna see.
So I'm giving you the...
You're gonna see this kind of convergence.
So he's doing this for about 10 years
through the revolution.
And eventually, we don't know the full story,
but he and caster have some sort of falling out
and they show up at my dad's factory one day and said,
you gotta go, you gotta go.
But that presupposes that they developed a relationship
of some sort of at some point--
Of some sort.
... around something.
Around something.
So your dad becomes this like industrialist, right?
Not the industrialist, but he's one of the few people
in Cuba that time who was a fluent speaker in Spanish
and Russian who had been in Cuba--
That makes it very valuable to Castro.
Very valuable.
Valuable enough and friendly enough
that they kicked him out which was great,
'cause a lot of people did not get that option.
They were just--
If you had to guess, what do you imagine the falling out
with Castro was about?
I'm sure you have theories on that.
But yeah, the theories it has to do with him
dating Castro's sister and other stuff like that.
Those are the--
The plot thickens.
I mean, knowing my dad as my dad.
And so there was something.
So Mexico wouldn't accept you
if you didn't have a round trip ticket.
So for many years we had the return ticket
from Mexico city back to Havana.
But he was told, never come back,
but he kept that return ticket.
Were you born?
You were born in Mexico.
I was born in Mexico.
So we're gonna pause on that story, and it's the mid '60s.
Meanwhile, so my dad's born in the '20s,
my mom is born in 1945
and she's kind of a radical artist student
in San Francisco Bay Area.
And she's working with Bill Graham and Janice Joplin
and doing all the posters for the Fillmore.
And she starts studying with an architect, an engineer
that's known but not totally known
by the name of Buckminster Fuller.
So Bucky becomes my mom's teacher.
That's so nice.
And so she ends up studying a bunch of time
with Buckminster Fuller.
So you're starting to see,
you're asking where Longpath came from,
but there's an etymology here.
Sure, now I get it.
And so spending a lot of time with Bucky,
he kind of helps her see the world in very different ways
and kind of thinking.
But what he eventually says is he goes,
look, you're only gonna go get so far in your thinking
if you stay within this kind of American context,
you need to go abroad.
But this is like the '60s.
It's not like today where you can jump on a plane
and go anywhere.
So the furthest her parents would let her go was Mexico.
So my mom ends up in Mexico,
20 year difference between my dad and her.
They get set up on a blind Shabbat date and they're married.
So you have this kind of Nazi hunting, Antifa,
anti-totalitarian, capitalist industrialist
with this kind of artsy, Bucky, younger American.
And myself and my children, sisters are born
in Guadalajara in the '70s.
Yeah, unbelievable.
And when you trace that etymology in the kind of strains
of thought, the polarity between your parents,
you can extract from each of those individuals aspects
that work kind of mend fluidly to create the person
that you are today.
'Cause it's this combination of being somebody
who really understands systems
and how to move entities, corporations, individuals,
political organizations forward in a progressive way,
but also this flare for creativity
and out of the box thinking.
Yeah, and the funny thing is when you're saying that,
I didn't know which parent you were talking about.
(Swan laughs)
Because there's a little bit of both of them.
My dad--
Well, I was thinking the systems comes from the dad.
Yeah, but Bucky was also a system.
Yeah, is as true, right?
My mom always saw the world in systems.
And so it's interesting,
it was a little bit of both in both of them,
obviously enough that there was an overlap.
It wasn't vinegar, oil, water.
It was like there was something there,
but there was enough overlap, but 100%.
Yeah, but also the shared DNA being this
kind of thinking that's untethered from tradition
or expectation to imagine a better future.
100%.
I mean, this was...
When my dad finally became an American citizen
in '80s, he was like, this is it, like I'm done.
And we were like, well, what do you mean you're done?
He was like, this was my revenge on Hitler.
My revenge on Hitler was getting to a free country
and having children
because all that he wanted for the Jews is
that we would all be killed and we'd always live
in a fascist state.
So for him, that telos, that ultimate aim was
for better or for worse,
not set up as something that he necessarily wanted
from the get go of life, it was something that he developed
by realizing he wanted the antithesis of the person
that he most hated in life.
That's not always the best way to go about doing it,
but given the circumstances, it makes sense.
So at what point does this young family move from Mexico
to the Bay Area?
So in the 1977, were in Guadalajara
and once again, antisemitism is kind of rearing its head
in Mexico and just even our Jewish day school would have
like armed guards following the school bus.
And eventually, it's funny I say eventually as if
of course, it's gonna happen.
But eventually the doors to our synagogue
are kind of machine gun on Yom Kippur is kind of a warning.
And my dad's like, I've seen this before,
and within two weeks we moved.
Didn't sell the business, didn't sell the house.
Kind of gave everything over to other people
to take care of.
Moving trucks came at 2:00 in the morning.
No one knew.
And the Bay Area, because your mom had roots there?
Yeah, my mom had roots in the Bay Area.
She came from an old kind of three generations
in the Bay Area, but before that Odessa, Russia.
Right, and so you're all of what?
Like eight or something like that at the time, younger?
I'm younger, I'm four years old.
Wow.
Four years old and English
at that point is my dad's 12th language.
So you're this young kid, you're getting indoctrinated
and all these amazing stories, you're intuiting the kind
of sensibility of your parents.
I'm sure there was interesting characters coming
through the house when you were a kid, right?
Yeah.
All of this is seeping in,
like what was your sense of who you wanted to be
as a young person?
I mean, look so you're right.
Like coming through the house,
one day it could be like former Nazi hunters
with just these crazy stories
and the next day it would be someone who was like,
look at this geodesic dome I built in the desert,
(indistinct) structure.
And I--
Was Bucky dropping by the house?
Bucky was gone by then.
(speaking over each other)
I don't know when he...
I think in the late '70s, '80s,
but he was no longer part of our picture
for whatever reason.
And I talk about this a little bit in the book.
But so family time was very important to my parents.
So we ate together probably six nights a week.
And the stories would always range
probably over 150 year span.
So my dad would be like, oh, when I was growing up
my parents would tell me these stories.
So we're talking like the 1910,
something from the shuttle.
But then my mom would talk about,
well, in 2118 we're gonna have this.
And they'd always be kind of looping them back in together.
So I always saw time the way I thought about it was,
well, of course I'm living in this kind of 150 year present.
Like it was never just the future, never was just the past,
but these things kind of overlapping
and kind of folding in on themselves.
Yeah, and no sense for how unusual or unique
that experience was, it was just normal.
That's just normal.
Yeah.
It's so interesting, 'cause I could,
I don't know that I could tell you much of anything
about my great grandparents.
It just wasn't part of the storytelling
or vernacular around our dinner table growing up.
Oh, it was parents, grandparents, great grandparents,
what recipes, what they ate, what they wore, everything.
Look, in many ways for better, for worse
and we're talking about like how I got to Longpath
and kind of the elements in it
around transgenerational empathy.
My dad was stuck in the 1920s or '30s.
Like when I would come home from soccer practice
or track or whatever,
he'd be there watching these kind of black
and white World War II movies.
But not watching them historically,
watching them because he was trying to figure out like,
could he have done something different?
What happened?
Like, that was the world...
It would be like us watching movies
from the 80s consistently
and our kids were always coming home
and were always watching.
Like me watching Fast Times at Ridgemont High which I--
But you as the teenage, Ari, aren't you thinking like,
come on dad, like get over it?
And your dad's like, there's threats around every corner
and kind of this fear mentality because of his upbringing
that I'm sure you were like,
I don't see that happening in my neighborhood.
I don't see it happening in our neighborhood,
but every time we went out to eat in a restaurant,
we would change tables often
because my dad never had his back to a door.
And then there--
The trauma of that experience.
Well, or being pragmatic.
I mean, for him it was both trauma
and like, at any moment who's coming through the door?
'Cause he had been in enough situations
where someone usually did come through the door
or something like that.
So I was kind of, I knew something was up by that
because I knew I was living,
this existence in the Bay Area in the '80s
and everything seemed fine,
but my dad was somewhere else.
He was very present, super present,
but it was obvious, he was always kind of,
when we think about kind of core traumas,
core, acute traumas, those, we either process them
and integrate or they hang over us.
And him coming from that kind of silent generation
where they weren't doing therapy, they weren't integrating,
it hung over him.
And so therefore, it hung over our house
and it hung over kind of how I saw the world,
not so much from a fear based modality,
but from a kind of, okay, when bad things happen
we have to work through it, we have to reconcile.
I mean, we solve for it, but we have to be open about it,
because I can see how you get stunted
and what could happen if you don't at an individual layer.
And that's why in Longpath,
when I talk about things like transgenerational empathy
about, at the individual organizational
or civilizational layer, that's like earned experience
'cause I see what happens when you don't do that.
Yeah, and the sense that
from a transgenerational perspective,
it's almost incumbent upon you to arrest the cycle
so that you don't perpetuate some kind of epigenetic thing
where you're carrying this fear based trait
or the negative aspects of your dad's sensibility
into the generation to come, into your kids and beyond.
And very early on in our conversation,
you're getting at the core of the book.
If we want to move forward as a species,
if homo sapiens are going to go further,
hundreds, if not thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands of years,
look, there's probably been between, depends on who you ask,
anywhere between 80 to a 100 billion homo sapiens alive
on the planet.
Once we start kind of saying homos sapiens,
we're kind of tracing.
Let's say a 100 billion so far to date.
We are looking at trillions of us in the future, right?
If we kind of account out
for the next several thousand years.
So the question and why I wrote this book is,
yes, we have to make it through this intertidal.
But if we don't start thinking about how we arrest
and work with those things that hold us back
as individuals and hold us back as societies,
we won't move forward, we'll actually start devolving.
So in many ways the book is kind of an attempt,
the mindset is an attempt to say,
Hey, look, if we want to build these futures,
these flourishing futures,
one of the things we're gonna have to do
is look to the past and reconcile.
Doesn't mean let the past off the hook,
doesn't mean that people who did atrocious things
are, oh, 'cause it's okay now,
but we're gonna have to unpack and work with that
if we wanna move forward.
Right, and I wanna get into the practicalities of that.
But to kind of dig a little bit deeper
into this inner title notion,
like I think that is what is sort of informing
the urgency of this book and your work,
because it is a moment of chaos
and it does feel like we're sort of
at this Rubicon moment
where if we don't figure this out right now,
it is gonna be cataclysmic.
And so the time is now to really start thinking about
and practicing these ideas,
because truly it does feel like,
and I'm interested in whether you agree with this,
that the future of humanity is at stake right now
with the existential crises that we're facing
and grappling with.
100%.
Look, we've been here before.
Probably the last major global intertidal was, again,
depend on who you ask, about 10,000 years ago,
the move from hunter gather to an agricultural society.
We literally went from you and I kind of walking
in the Serengeti, eating what we needed to eat,
resting where we needed to rest and sleep,
getting up in the morning and kind of moving on.
There was that.
And then all of a sudden we realize that we can move away
from living in that way and kind of rest and start sewing
and growing and all sorts of things come out of that.
The one thing that comes out of it though
is that we have to start making new stories
and new rules and new ways of being.
And other people have written about this.
Probably one of the biggest things that comes out of
the agricultural revolution is this idea of God.
Because back in the day,
if it was just 30 of us in a tribe moving around,
I knew everything that you did,
you knew everything that I did.
Morality in a certain sense was instantaneous.
Like if you shirked off your responsibilities,
we all knew it.
But what happens in the agricultural revolution is
as we start kind of urbanizing and moving into cities
and literally start building walls and rooms,
we're no longer all around each other.
So there's no longer this all seen Rich or Ari.
And so we need something, the kind of lockdown rules
so no one in a kind of prisoner's dilemma screws around.
The omnipotent accountability machine.
Yes, or the panopticon, also known as God, right?
'Cause God is in every room, God is all seen.
Now there was gods, and there's God, and there's,
we can play with that.
But the idea being, this is how you kind of structure
and order society.
These are now the rules.
There's now something bigger than you
that's going to kind of push us forward and help us evolve.
Now that's the last kind of major intertidal.
I would say another one,
and this is through obviously a Western perspective,
is the fall of the Roman Empire.
And most intertidals much like today come about
because you have kind of ecological collapse,
mass migration, you're overspending on wars,
I mean, it just sound kind of familiar,
and you let your kind of domestic situation fall apart
and you get inequality.
We had this in the Roman Empire, the east and the west,
there's actually two of them.
One was taking care of the other
and the whole thing fell apart.
Now what came about in that intertidal was obviously
the rise of the church.
And hence the middle ages.
Which, we don't use the term--
That was an inner title that went sideways.
So that was an inner title that went bad.
I mean, we used to call it the dark ages,
but we realize you shouldn't say...
That's a very loaded term.
But we say the middle ages and it was not a pretty time.
Now, one thing to note about what happens
in the intertidal is people start to freak out.
'Cause as you noted, there's chaos, there's flux,
the old rules and narratives kind of start to melt away
and people are looking around and saying, whoa,
what's going on?
Like, what are the answers?
And so in that inter title, the church comes along and says,
well, this is it.
These are the rules, these are the answers.
Do it this way and you'll be okay,
you'll be saved in the afterlife.
An amazing invention, right?
Because then all of a sudden you start doing everything
in this little thing of your life,
because for all of eternity
you're either gonna be here in heaven or hell.
So it's a great kind of command and control mechanism.
The big takeaway there though is that people are seeking
an authoritative voice when you move
into an intertidal moment.
And so fast forward to now, we are in a similar thing,
we have all those same issues.
The difference now is whereas technology
would almost be an amplifier of an intertidal,
would kind of like the wheel or canal systems.
Now technology has the ability to actually rethink
what it means to even be human.
So this is obviously CRISPR genetic engineering,
artificial uteri, AI machine learning,
brain machine interfaces.
So now technology is actually part of that.
The thing that I am most kind of sensitive
to given what we talked about my upbringing is,
what happens to people when in this intertidal moment,
kind of this official future that we've been living
in starts to die and there are no answers,
we start looking for strong voices.
We've seen that around the world,
we're seeing it right now.
So now I'm gonna add another thing onto the table.
So yes, we're facing kind of, we're in this pivotal moment.
What we do or don't do in the next 10 to 15 years
will have a knock on effect for hundreds
if not thousands of years.
On top of that, at the very time
we need to maximize our ability
to cooperate globally, planetarily.
We have the rise of voices that are kind of
retrograde futurists saying I alone can fix it, follow me.
And the way they're able to kind of command and control
is by saying, you either with me or you're against me,
they're either with us or against us.
And so that's the second thing that is making me
kind of the most nervous about this moment.
Well, and that's also compounding this increased level
of distrust in organizations from everything political
to media oriented.
So the whole fabric of the way that we communicate
and create consensus is under threat at the moment as well,
which clearly obviously undermines our ability
to problem solve in a coherent manner.
And people say, well, how do you know you're kind of
entering into an intertidal,
or you're in an intertidal?
Like, what are the metrics behind that?
And we'll talk later about the metrication of everything.
But on metric in that is people's levels of trust
in institutions, in the institutions
that have been guiding us since the kind of last world
that we were in the last tide.
So we can kind of trace us back.
What we're coming out of really is
we're coming outta the enlightenment
where bacon and others, is obviously the renaissance,
but then we go into kind of the scientific revolution
and the enlightenment.
And one of the most amazing things that comes out of that
is they undercut the power of the church.
The problem is we throw the baby out with the bathwater.
We take away the kind of power dynamics of the church,
which is great,
but we also take out kind of the mystical and spiritual.
We'll get back to that in a second.
So now what we have is a world where we can start
to understand everything as we break it down
by its basic component parts.
So this microphone, I take it apart
and there's a thousand parts on the table
and I can figure out how it works.
And that makes sense for hundreds of years.
The issue is that's actually not how the world works,
that's not how the planet works.
If you go to a rainforest and you take out one tree here
and a little bit of dirt here, the whole thing collapses.
There's interdependence.
But the systems that we've been in
for the past several hundred years don't allow for that.
And so what ends up happening is those institutions,
be it finance, governance, Congress, whatever it is,
they're now breaking down under the pressures
and the strains of this moment.
And when they break down, people like you
and I who live in this system,
because of the social contract, start to lose trust.
When I see people running to crypto,
people look at it a lot of different ways.
I see that as a lack of trust in banking systems.
When I see people running to certain things,
I'm like, what institution are they no longer trusting
that they're now going to this?
Again, to me, signs of the intertidal.
Yeah, but within all of these breakdowns
and the precariousness of the moment,
the other aspect of the intertidal is this opportunity,
like this like Petri dish for creativity.
So now is our moment.
The Longpath mindset is this kind of optimistic,
hopeful antidote to the cynicism with this mental model
that is requiring us to think more long term.
And from my perspective or the way,
I'm kind of like absorbing this material in your book,
I'm confronted with my own kind of limitations
or hard wiring as a human being.
Like I just think, and you talk about the hardware,
software problem of the human mind,
like, I'm just not wired to think like that.
Like it is a practice and I'm sure with practice,
you can expand your capacity
to think about these pillars that you talk about,
but it's so counterintuitive
and it runs against all of my kind of
built in incentive structures.
Yeah, yes.
When you say wired,
we have to talk about what that means, right?
Because we often think and fall back on this idea
that, well, actually homo sapiens are hardwired
for short term.
Well, short term thinking short term action.
And so, yes.
You and I were back 15,000 years ago in the Serengeti
and a big animal with big teeth starts chasing us.
You and I are not gonna sit down and have a conversation
about, well, what should we do?
How should we deal with it?
How do we get into?
We're gonna run.
And we're gonna run so fast
that we're running before we even processed it.
So that obviously, that limbic system,
the amygdala is taking over.
Thank God and getting us outta that situation.
Now at the same time though,
let's go back to the agricultural revolution.
There are two things, Marty Seligman,
University of Pennsylvania talks a lot about this.
I dunno if you've had Marty, but if not--
No.
So Marty talks about, one of the issues is,
he calls us homo prospectus.
So he's the father of positive psychology.
So the kind of the first big idea he had
and this comes up a little bit in the book
is that we always are focused on our pathologies
at a psychological level.
Like what are the things that are wrong?
Not what are the things that are right?
What are the things that lead to us being more flourishing?
So the DSM four, five, and six, and seven
will consistently clinically look at the things
that put you on the couch
'cause something's wrong with you.
But the field rarely looks at what's right.
How do we actually get better as humans?
So that's one thing Marty did that shows up in Longpath.
The second is, he says look,
the thing that separates homo sapiens
from any other mammalian or really any other species
are two things, one, our ability to cooperate
and two, our ability for a prospection,
to think ahead, right?
So other animals can do this.
Other animals, you can see this in primates,
Sapolsky talks about this.
They'll kind of cooperate on something,
maybe they'll all get sticks to kind of go
into the ant hill.
But what they won't do necessarily is say,
Hey, let's create a factory of sticks
and we'll bring these Iranian tanks here at this time,
they don't do that.
We do that extremely well.
That is thankfully the prefrontal cortex, right?
That's this executive functioning that allows us.
This goes to the hard wiring that sits on top of
the limbic system that allows us to actually plan
for the future.
Now what ends up happening is yes,
so we're hardwired for this,
we're hardwired to think long term,
but then the incentive structures of society.
So here's where it gets interesting.
The actual cultural code,
and again, I'm tracing this back to the past 400 years
the industrial revolution and we'll get into that.
Those are the incentive structures.
So you biologically rich for the past 10,000 years,
you're golden, you can do this.
This is already in you.
It's what's around you, it's how we monetize,
it's how our ego gets fed.
It's all these other things that have been incentivized
because of the way we run our society and economy today
that leads to it becoming difficult.
So Longpath as an antidote to short-termism
isn't an antidote to the amygdala or the limbic system.
In many ways, it's an antidote to the systems
that we have kind of been surrounded by
that have incentivizing our behavior
over the past couple hundred years.
Yeah I mean, I think it's almost all about incentives.
'Cause when you look at some of the largest,
if not, the vast majority of the largest problems
that we face, whether it's world hunger
or climate collapse,
we actually have everything we need right now
to solve those problems.
Everybody could be housed and fed,
like there's enough resources for everybody.
The impediments are all human or human constructed
and a lot of them track back to the incentive structures
that we've created that drive at least bad decisions
for long term solutions.
Yep. 100%.
So what you just said is a quote
that I heard a very early age by Buckmister Fuller,
which is we have the ability to house clothes feed
and educate everyone on the planet.
Why don't we?
And so I was asked this at a very young age
and it just kind of always hung over me.
So that's why I got in...
What I ended up studying at UC Berkeley was peace
and conflict studies, which is this interesting major
that's both international relations and psychology
with a little bit of religion thrown in.
So that question, why don't we
is the one that has been driving most of my work
for most of my life.
Right.
And you see it cutting across every sector politics.
We have election cycles, raise money, get into office
and it's all about making sure you stay in office.
Quarterly earnings, like everything, right?
The incentive structure is set up for short term gain
without consideration for the long term implications.
So without eradicating those incentive structures
and building better ones,
and maybe this is what you're doing at at Longpath Labs,
like how to do this.
Without that we're sort of shouldering it
as individuals like,
well, you should be thinking about,
like that's not gonna solve it.
Like it's a good practice and we should all be doing that.
And obviously there's a ripple effect to that
that seeps into our institutions
and how we conceptualize them and conduct them.
But we need both that grassroots individual shift
as well as institutional revolution, really.
Yeah, and look, we're starting to see this.
They're creating the kind of the long term stock exchange
where the longer you hold a stock,
the more you actually have voting power.
We see some of these new things being built interestingly
at a Silicon valley,
which in many ways has been driving rampant short-termism.
But even from that,
that kind of disruptive spirit is getting us things like
the long term stock exchange.
It's my belief that it is both,
it is kind of a bottom up and a top down.
But the top down more often than not
is only in a response to something coming from the bottom.
Everything that I've seen in terms of social change
over the past several decades, very...
I'm trying to think of an example where it was coming
from the top that actually made the change.
It may have come from the top,
but they were really kind of seeing the signals down below.
(upbeat music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores
of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling profits on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change" Volume 2.
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration, and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll Podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table
and volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday profits
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained within.
"Voicing Change" Volume 2,
available now while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
So in terms of getting into the practicalities
of how to achieve this,
I mean, we should probably talk about these pillars.
I mean, you've talked a little bit
about transgenerational empathy,
but there's a lot more to that
and then you have these two other pillars as well.
Yeah.
So in my '20s, maybe like a lot of people
in their '20s in the Bay Area,
I spent a lot of time at green girl check
kind of the Soto Zen Center, (indistinct) Zen Center.
So I'm a kind of a cultural religious Jew.
I'm thinking about going to rabbinical school,
I'm doing a bunch of stuff
at a kind of a Soto Zen Retreat Center,
and I'm also reading a lot of work by Krishnamurti.
So this is kind of like my...
You're familiar with all these and like with--
You're like this perfect Bay Area prototype.
Oh, such a cliche.
Like driving to my old Subaru, but like--
Going to Berkeley.
Yeah, so I'm thinking couple of things
as I'm seeing this in my '20s is that,
and this is really the influence of Krishnamurti,
who I came to by the way through David Bom, the physicist.
So I wasn't seeking out Krishnamurti
this Indian philosopher,
I was actually looking at how we think
about quantum mechanics and quantum physics
and nuclear fusion energy to solve the Middle East crisis.
This is my major at Berkeley.
And so somehow I read an article by this guy, David Bom
and the holographic universe
and then I see all of a sudden he's in conversation
with this guy named Krishnamurtie
and that I'm off to the races with Krishnamurti
for the next 10 years.
And one of the things that kind of the takeaways
from Krishnamurti was, and I talked about this earlier,
is that any time...
Well look, Krishnamurti one his kind of famous sayings
is truth is a pathless land,
which means you only come to truth by knowing it
through yourself and by investigating your own mind.
And any time anyone puts out a very kind of specific dogma
of steps, you are now following in their steps,
you are not following the truth to your own mind.
And so that was always in the background
when I was thinking about this kind of mindset
that I think we need to navigate this.
And title is one that would have pillars, but not steps.
That's why I'm circling back to this idea of pillars.
So there's really two pillars or two and a half,
I don't how we slice the chapters.
So the first one is transgenerational empathy,
and I'll come back to that in a second.
The other is futures thinking,
so future with with an S.
And part of futures thinking is telos
or ultimate aim and ultimate goal.
So those are the three pillars of Longpath.
Transgenerational empathy is having a kind of understanding
and a constant activation that you are part
of the great chain of being,
you are part of what came before you,
you are present in the moment
and aligned with what's happening
and you are part of what's going to happen in the future.
Now the reason that is so,
it sounds obvious when you hear like, oh, of course,
but we have this what I call lifespan bias.
So if you look at, go to the bookstore,
every kind of self-help book is about,
like rich from birth to death,
like here's what you can do.
And that's a very Western modality, right?
It's a very kind of truncated.
It's all about you.
It's a very kind of no offense to anyone,
but it's a very kind of almost narcissistic way
of thinking about your role in the world
is that it's just from your birth to your death.
And it discounts what came before you
and what's gonna come after you.
So transgenerational empathy asks you to look back
at your parents, and your grandparents,
and your great grandparents,
at an individual level
and understand that what they did shaped who you are today
for better or for worse.
And at the core of it,
and the reason why it's not transgenerational thinking,
but empathy is so that you can connect with them
and understand what they were going through,
why did they make those decisions,
and how is that impacting you?
Now that doesn't mean you let them off the hook.
If your parents did something terrible,
transitional empathy doesn't mean,
well, I absolve you.
But it means it means having a conversation,
if they're alive or if they're not
and investigating that.
It's a kind of, it's looking at the emotional inheritance
that you received from those who came before you
at an individual level,
but also a societal level
and saying, okay, I understand that
that is present in me in these certain ways,
but it doesn't have to define who I am.
So if we go back to the story of my father, yeah.
Anyone listening to this is like,
oh, that dude's dad definitely had PTSD
undiagnosed and untreated
and that definitely manifests in Ari's life
with his anxiety and the way he looks
at the world, da, da, da.
So transgenerational empathy is understanding
what my dad had, why he had it,
why my dad harbored kind of anger towards his parents
for not leaving Europe, for not existing
and not living through it and making different decisions.
So it's understanding that that came
and that's at the individual layer.
And at the present moment,
it's about having self-compassion for yourself.
So empathy for yourself means, okay, I am who I am,
I'm doing the best that I can
as opposed to kind of constantly beating yourself up
against a metric and saying,
well, I could be that much better,
I could be that...
Because a lot of us are strivers,
like we're always,
the only yard stick we use is this imaginary one
that we somehow develop,
but we didn't somehow develop.
Just like the voice in our head
that came from something before us.
So it's about doing this kind of emotional,
it's almost like archeology.
Like going through the layers saying,
okay, that's who I am,
I'm doing the best I can.
Now what do I do to align myself to the present moment
and take action and change my behaviors,
not just for me right now and those around me,
but for those who are to come.
So transgenerational empathy is asking you to connect
in a true, authentic, emotional way
with unborn generations.
It could be your own spawn,
you're great, great, great,
or just those who are to come.
And so someone might be listening to this
and like, well, that's great,
why don't you just skip to the end?
Just why don't we just have empathy with the future?
Why don't we need to go to the past or the present?
Well, everything that I learned as a kind of futurist
and a strategist and kind of thinking
about how we develop a mindset for this moment
developing Longpath is,
humans don't do a good job of just jumping forward.
So the way the hippocampus works, right?
It constructs the future off of past memories.
So in some ways when I ask you to think about the future,
the images that you conjure up
are kind of these pixel later changed images of the past.
And so if we don't work to kind of clean up those images
of the past, of what brought you here,
you're only gonna kind of project that trauma
and those issues out into the future.
So the reason transgenerational empathy has you start
in the past, is so when it comes time to go forward,
you're doing it with as clean as slate as possible.
Right.
Yeah, I really like that.
So the distinction between something
that might be called transgenerational understanding
into transgenerational empathy is due
to the fact that you have to heal that relationship
with your fore bearers, right?
Like to empathize with them is to truly understand them
so that you can kind of embrace that legacy
from a perspective of love rather than resentment
that you will then project onto future generations
and then some kind of vicious cycle ensues.
And so I mentioned this, my glory days.
So I ran the four by 100 in track in high school.
Oh, I bet, I didn't know.
And so anyone who's run track knows,
especially a relay race knows you win or lose these races
in the transition zone.
And so when you're running up into the translation zone,
you yell stick and the person in front of you
puts their hand out to grab the stick.
They can't look at you,
because if they do, they'll go outta their lane
or they're missed a zone and they'll get disqualified.
So there's a huge trust there
when you yell stick in this transition zone.
And what I learned very on from my coach,
Coach Ted Tillian is, if there has been a mistake
at some other point, the way you are going to,
yes, you're gonna run as quick as you can,
but they're also really quick.
But where you're gonna actually change the future outcome
of that race is in that transition zone, is in that handoff.
So when I think about transgenerational empathy,
it's to your point, how are we giving as clean a stick
as possible to future generations
at an emotional level?
You notice we're not talking about
where we haven't gone and where folks may...
Well, why aren't you talking about AI
or climate change, or big...
Yes, in the book I talk about mega trends
in these massive issues.
The fact of the matter is most of us are not in a position
to directly impact where we're gonna get our power from.
All these other issues, we can do it at a micro level,
and I'll talk about that in a sec with trim tabs,
and it's how we consume or how we vote.
But in general, our legacy,
what we pass on to future generations is those emotions.
It's what we either have or have not cleaned out.
That when we say stick and we hand it to other people,
it's on us, what we pass forward.
Yeah, this is tried and true in psychology.
Like I just know from my own personal lived experience,
unresolved issues that I have with my mother or my father
that are not adequately healed,
I see getting played out in the manner
in which I interact with my kids.
And my wife is the first person to say,
you're doing that thing again.
If you don't go back and heal that thing from the past,
you are perpetuating something
that is gonna show up in their lives
throughout adulthood and the time is now.
And so basically Longpath is a way
of kind of telescoping up on that idea
and looking at it as a cultural phenomenon
with massive ripple effects in how we co-create the future,
whether it be something that is
of our utopian dreams or of our dystopian nightmares.
Yeah, and you hit the nail on the head.
We can start to actually extrapolate this
into higher layers.
So what that means is,
as a society, how do we do that?
We were seeing this kind of...
So in South Africa there was the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission at the end of apartheid.
It wasn't perfect, it didn't heal everything,
but it allowed people to kind of come together
and have a process to try to kind of
not eviscerate the past,
but to understand it in a way that they could kind of
move together and kind of create literally these scenarios
about what South Africa is moving forward.
Brian Stevenson from the Equal Justice Initiative says,
"There's no way I could go to Germany if they had kind of,
and I'm paraphrasing, if they had torn down all
the concentration camps,
if there were no kind of monuments."
I couldn't do it because they're living kind of
an unreconciled and unlooked at way of the past.
Instead, when you go to Berlin,
I was just there, in the middle of Berlin,
there's a huge Memorial to the Holocaust.
Every house that was taken from a Jewish family
has a plaque on it.
The camps are still up in Germany, in Poland,
they're still doing it.
You come to America and it's like the exact opposite,
like we hide it.
It didn't happen.
And so what you see now happening
and it has been happening is like we're taking down statues,
we're doing some of the things that we should have done
in one way or another.
Now if it up to me, the statutes that have been taken down,
instead of necessarily melting them down or scrapping them,
we would actually put them somewhere
and we would go visit those parks
and look at that like, that's who we are,
like that's a part of us.
Just like when German kids go to visit places in Germany,
they say, oh, this is part of our software,
this is part of how we were wired at some point
and we have to pay attention.
'Cause it's a slippery slope to get back there
and what worries me is a society that doesn't do that,
that doesn't have an honest conversation with its past.
Yeah, and we're not very good at that.
I mean, truth and reconciliation is
such an amazing example of Longpath mindset
because it considers the implications
of how its citizenship is going to interact
with each other for generations to come.
And it recognizes like we need to deal with this now
because if we don't our nation will be fractured
in the future.
And you look at the United States
and you can't help but think,
how would things be different?
Had do we enacted reparations,
like meaningful reparations
or some form of truth and reconciliation
because when you look at the fractured race relations
that we deal with right now,
it really all tracks back to our failure,
inability to reconcile appropriately.
Yeah.
And the question is like, so why do we do that?
Like, why do we fail?
So I know we're in transgeneration empathy,
but we can't go forward if we don't talk about fear.
And so if we think about the things that we do or do not do,
and again, this is the evolutionary biologist in me,
and many people would differ.
I trace a lot of what we do and don't do
based on Ari and Rich in a cave 20,000 years ago,
like those kind of reactions.
So if we kind of have a truth telling
about something that went wrong,
Rich may push Ari outta the cave.
I might not make it through the night.
And so our kind of our innate,
we think our innate survival instinct
is to kind of push past the things that were wrong
and kind of just move forward,
and kind of ignore it,
and kind of brush it under the rug.
And time and time again,
be it in terms of race relations,
in terms of world wars, in terms of couples counseling
and couples therapy, the things that we don't talk about
are still there and they still rear up.
And so part of why we have transformational empathy
with the past, present and future,
is so that when it comes time to have interactions
with the future self, we are as kind of ready
and kind of clear about what it is that we want.
We're not taking that baggage with us.
Yeah, and there's some interesting science about
that piece of forecasting into the future
and being in conversation with your future self.
Can you talk about that a little bit?
'Cause I think it's pretty revealing.
We'll get to the other pillars in a second
kind of futures and telos.
But one of the things what we want people to do is
obviously connect to future generations.
But before you can connect to future generations,
be it your great, great grandkids,
or even unborn generations,
hundreds of generations from now,
you have to actually connect with your future self.
You have to understand that there are some kind of
limitations already right there.
So one of our advisory board members, Hal Hershfield
at UCLA does this amazing research
where it's always freshman students, right?
That's like half of our science is basically freshman.
He's stuck in FMR machine.
Just to be totally clear, that's...
So he'll kinda--
That's so true.
He'll put them into FMR machines, right?
So you can kind see the oxygen flow
and see where the energy if you will in the brain.
And he asks him a very specific question.
He goes, okay, I want you to think of yourself right now.
And this is not technically what it is.
But like, this part of the brain will light up, right?
Like around here, but it's everywhere,
but we're not gonna crack my head open.
So this part will light up.
And then you'll say, okay, I want you to think of,
and it changes but he's like,
I want you to think of Matt Damon.
So it's someone that everyone kind of knows
but extensively doesn't know no.
And so like this part of the brain will light up.
And then he'll say, okay,
I want you to think about yourself 10 years from now.
And you know exactly what happens.
For almost everyone,
the part that lit it for Matt Damon likes up
for their future self.
That's how disconnected we are from our future self,
what we call kind of future self continuity
is how we measure it.
So Hal pulls 'em out and other people have done this,
but I think Hal does done some of the best work.
And he'll do all these different kind of interventions.
And the two that are, well, there's three.
But the two I'll talk about is,
he will take an image of them and he'll age it 10 years
and he'll have 'em look at it every day
for a couple of minutes.
And then another thing he'll do is,
he'll have 'em write a letter to their future self
that will get delivered to them 10 years from now.
Now the third thing that he does is,
he's kinda the combination of the first two.
But they'll actually scan you
and they'll put you in a VR environment
where you're kind of walking around
and all of a sudden you look in a mirror
and there you are age 10 years.
So that's the most sophisticated version of this.
So you know what happens, right?
They put 'em back in the FMR machine,
30, 60, 90 days later, people who had nothing done,
it's the same distinction, current RA, future RA.
Those who have actually looked at photos of themselves aged
or have written letters to their future self,
now start to have much more overlap in the region.
So they connect future self and current self
are almost completely overlapped.
And we would do this at Longpath.
We would run these kind of interventions
with crowds that we would gather in New York City
for these kind of evening of Longpathing.
And what we have them do is,
it's a simple test actually that how develop
kind of a way of how connected you are
to your future self.
You would draw a circle on a piece of paper
and that's you right now.
And then you'd say, draw another circle that represents,
let's say you in 10 years from now.
And so you kind of know what happened.
For most people, the circles are always be pretty far apart.
Where you wanna get people to is where the circles
are actually overlapping each other,
where your connection to your future self
and your current self are almost one and the same.
Now you're like, well, Ari, this is really interesting,
who's funding all these experiments?
Who do you think is funding the experiments?
Mostly life insurance companies.
Companies, not mostly.
Interesting.
People who need to figure out how to get people
to put away savings for the future.
Now we've taken that work at Longpath
and we've integrated into the work that we do.
And so, by the way, if anyone's interested
in writing a letter to your future self
or looking at a photo of yourself age 10 years,
you can go to longpath.org/futureme,
and we've kind of set up two different ways of doing that.
You can write a letter to your future self
and you can age yourself 10 years now.
I don't wanna give this away, but I'm about to.
It's not about receiving the letter,
it's about writing the letter that actually does it.
Now I wanna go back to something
that you picked up on earlier,
which is, it's not transgenerational thinking,
it's transgenerational empathy.
So as we're kind of closing out this pillar,
this empathy for future generations, yes,
first and foremost we have to develop empathy
for our future self.
So these kind of experiments and these kind of ways do that.
And there's a bunch of exercises in the book
that also allow that to happen.
But then the question becomes why emotions?
Why do we ground the work in this mindset
through what we call pro social emotion?
So it's not transgenerational guilt,
it's not transgenerational anger,
it's transgenerational empathy, this pro social emotion.
The reason we do that is because,
and this is from David DeSteno lab in Northeastern
and a bunch of other people.
Is that, and this goes back to Marty Salman,
we often think of emotions as something
about how we deal with the past.
But what many folks think and believe and I do
is that emotions are actually there to guide future action.
They're actually there so when it comes,
you hurt when something bad happens
and you feel emotionally pained,
it's so you won't do that again in the future.
So you won't date that guy again or someone like him.
That's why you hurt in a breakup.
So the reason we have empathy for future generations
and we ground it in the pro social
is because based on how's work and others,
what actually will drive Ari or Rich
to execute against a goal or to take specific behaviors
for that goal, for those future generations
is being emotionally connected to them.
Sure. Yeah.
I mean, you can...
We all intellectually understand
that it's in our best interest long term to save money
or do all of these things
that basically a lot of us don't do,
because we're not, we lack that emotional connection.
And what I think is so interesting about
what you just shared is,
beyond creating the empathetic connection to our past,
Longpath thinking in terms of future casting starts
with your relationship with yourself.
And as these FMRI studies demonstrate,
our brains are neuroplastic
that when we do these exercises
we can actually create new pathways
that hopefully over time and with practice become more
and more entrenched.
And that emotional connection to your future self
is really what drives behavior.
It's not the intellectualization of it.
No.
That's the courtesy in the whole thing.
I can show you a million PowerPoints
on why you should say for the future,
why you should floss.
But if I show you an image of your teeth falling out
30 years from now and then ask you,
how do you feel, seeing that, you're gonna start flossing.
Right, but you also have to develop
that empathetic connection to your future self
before that will even work is what you're saying.
And what I'm also saying is,
before you can have that empathetic connection
to your future self, you have to develop
that empathy with the past and that self-compassion.
Because if you aren't connected there,
there's too many blockages,
there's too much trauma and anger for you
to actually project out in the future,
you become locked into.
So what I read about in the book is this
kind of presentism.
There's where like the here,
and not presentism in the Buddha sense,
but presentism were like in a hall of mirrors
where we become a historical,
there's no future, there's no past.
And in that feeling of kind of yuckiness and anger,
we become unable to move forward in any way, shape or form.
And so part of why it's transgenerational is
we're breaking ourselves outta that presentist moment.
If you look at ISIS or if you look at kind of
any hard right political movement right now,
they're very a historical in a certain way.
Because what they're doing is they're tapping
into our frustrations and distrust of the current moment
and then amplifying it.
And so part of what transgenerational empathy does is
it breaks you out of it.
It breaks you out of this kind of ego fold
of it's just me and just my life,
so you can expand both forward and backward.
Yeah, and the presentism is interesting
because, not that long ago,
I mean, I think we all can kind of,
there's a consensus that we are in this inner titled moment.
But it was not that long ago when it was quite fashionable
to say that we were living in a moment beyond history.
It's all good, we're locked in,
this is the way it's gonna be,
which makes it all the more shocking
to be in this chaotic kind of culture and environment
that we find ourselves.
Look, I was going to UC Berkeley
when Francis Fukuyama wrote The End of History.
And for someone who was studying international relations,
I mean, that's what this article was.
What am I studying?
It's over.
Like the liberal west--
Why look backwards?
Why look anything?
And now it's the end of history.
We're in this kind of steady state
and that's going to be it.
And anytime anyone has ever said that,
they've always been proven wrong.
Like we're always kind of going--
You're augering like a shift just by saying it out loud,
I think.
And so what ends up...
So the reason Francis, I won't speak for Francis Fukiyama.
But one of the reasons I feel he wrote that is
'cause what he saw was a world in which the official future,
the narrative about the kind of
the shared set of assumptions and belief
about what tomorrow will be like
had actually now locked in.
So this is the second pillar of Longpath,
it's futures thinking versus future thinking.
So in the official future, the singular,
we all kind of decide, well, this is what it's going to be
and this is what it's going to kind of look like
over the next several decades.
The official future has always been with us,
but it's always changed.
And the thing to know about the official future
are two things.
One, someone usually comes up with it
and develops it for us, and we can talk about that in a sec.
And two, we actually want it.
It's cognitively taxing to live in a totally open world
where anything could happen.
There's certain homo sapiens going back to our why
and like we need some constant,
we need to know something is going to be constant.
'Cause if it's consistently chaotic,
it's too much and we overly we kind of burn out.
So this kind of intertidal
where we talk about the things that are dying
and the things that have not yet been born,
the things that we were living through
that Fukuyama was looking at was
kind of this enlightenment mechanistic,
neoliberal world order where
there's the famous Clinton quote,
two countries of the McDonald's
have never fought each other,
which obviously it happened when there was one
in Ukrainian and one in Moscow.
It's a great example,
I never thought about it of actually the real,
and you know you're intertidal when two nation states
with McDonald's fight each other.
It goes against Clinton's Axiom.
All of it in that context.
The Clintonian Axiom.
And so the official future now that we're kind of in,
has very much been dictated, at least,
over the past several decades
by kind of the industrial revolution and technology.
So if we think about in the 1930s
at the World's Fair in New York,
there's an amazing exhibit called Future Rama, Future Rama,
that's, what else you need to know.
But it was actually paid for
and put together by General Motors.
So it's all these amazing visions of tomorrow,
the kitchen of tomorrow,
but the one constant as you kind of went in these
kind of chairs around the future arm exhibit
is everywhere you went there was four
and eight lane highways,
'cause that was baked into the official feature.
Now if your General Motors, that makes sense,
you better have eight lane highways in the future.
So the official future through GM's perspective
was a car-centric one.
And you better believe that's very much how we developed,
at least, here in the US for several decades,
because that was the official future.
What ends up happening intertidal is
those official futures start to break down.
And the one we have right now,
and we're actually seeing a battle for official futures.
There's the uploaders, singulatarians, techno fetish folks,
there's Neo romantics.
All people trying to say, well, this is the solar punk.
I'm agnostic on that 'cause I have to be
because I'm not saying it should be this one
or should be that one.
What I'm saying is we have to think in the intertidal
through a future's lens,
that there are potentially multiple tomorrows
that we could be heading towards
and we have to judge each one on its own merit.
And by the way, those can all kind of coexist.
So this idea of the official future
that we all have to live within,
I think is something that we can kind of put to the side.
So why it's a pillar of Longpath is in much of the same way
that transgeneration empathy kind of breaks you out
of your stupor about the path dictating the present
and the future.
Futures thinking breaks down this narrative
that there can only be a singular future.
I get invited to speak on these panels all the time,
the future of food or the future of transportation
and I would say, look, unless you put an S on it,
I'm not coming.
Because what you're saying is,
what we're gonna talk about is this one singular thing
and there isn't one kind of singular thing.
So that's the core of futures thinking
and the kind of futures cone which we can go into
is why that's such an important kind of pillar of Longpath.
Yeah, you have this illustration in the book of this cone,
I forget the person who came up with this idea.
But basically over time as the cone widens,
you have this official future
that's kind of the center of the cone.
And then from there concentric circles
or sort of almost a semi Venn diagram
kind of way of displaying potential futures
and differences in what might be.
And I think, I understand everything you said.
The part that maybe you can help me with a little bit
that I'm not sure, I totally understand
is the dissonance between the importance of forecasting
that future of your desires as a kind of benchmark
to work towards to use to extend
the kind of athlete metaphor like you can't achieve
your goal unless you know what you're working towards
versus this sort of panoply of multiple futures.
Like that becomes confusing.
What exactly?
Do we have consensus around here
and what are we collectively aiming for?
So this gets into the second part of
that futures pillar, which is telos,
which is ultimate aim and ultimate goal.
So first and foremost, we have to realize that telos
isn't an end point, it's not kind of a noun or a place,
it's a horizon line.
And so different people, if you're an athlete,
you're telos, an ultimate aim is a level of fitness
and way of being that allows you kind of flourish
on a physical, mental level, let's say, as an individual.
It's not like, oh, I will weigh this much
and I can do this many reps,
but it's something much bigger than that,
so when we think of the ultimate aim.
So the Voros cone, the cones that are in the book,
so there's this official future in the middle.
So far in our conversation, we've kind of gotten away
with that official future.
And part of, the way the Voros originally did it
was it kind of the the ice cream cone on its side,
if you will, starts in the present.
So we've done it Longpaths kind of expanded out
and bring the past into it.
And so we're saying, well,
you never just start in the present,
you're actually starting from something
that was given or hoisted onto you.
So let's start there.
So that's our slight change to the Voros cone.
So in the center, we have the official future.
Now we've talked about why that can be disingenuous
in terms of us kind of trying to move the ball forward
as individuals or just species.
And so you've talked about these different circles.
So the next kind of concentric circle
is this idea of plausible futures, right?
So these are the things that could happen outside
of this official future.
And so what you do is you kind of play in that space, right?
And so it depends if you're talking about an athlete
or a country, or a world, or a species.
Well, a couple of different things could happen.
We could upload, we could falter,
we could go extinct, we could go towards flourishing.
So it allows us to not be totally polyannish.
And the way we kind of ring the rim around that
is by talking about kind of the mega trends.
So there's mega trends in the book.
They're in the back of the book,
but at Longpath we look at 21 different mega trends
across science, human conditions, psychology, climate.
These are kind of tectonic forces
that have been with us for decades.
And so what they do is they almost act
as guardrails about what are kind of some plausible futures.
Now there's always gonna be possible futures.
That's the next kind of cone that kind of...
We wanna do is say, we're not totally circumscribed
by the plausible.
So some of the possible maybe aliens come,
so that even outside of the plausible.
But we wanna show that we're open to that.
The final one, which is what you're getting at
is this idea of the desired future
or what we call in the book examined desired future.
The reason it's examined is it's not just a future
that you want to aim towards
because you've been told by society that's the goal
to become a doctor or a lawyer, make a billion dollars.
It's one, you've examined it by looking at your past,
how you were shaped, again, this is individual or societal,
and then saying, okay, I was shaped and told
that my desired future should be X,
but when I examine this kind of emotional baggage
or inheritance for better or for worse,
I realize that my desired future maybe shifted
over a little bit.
And that becomes your personal goal
or society's personal goal.
You can still have multiple
kind of examined desired futures,
but as long as they're examined.
Right.
So an example in the Future Roma context would be
to examine this eight lane highway.
Like what's behind that?
Well, fluid transportation,
how do you get from one place to the next expeditiously?
Well, to examine it would be to say,
what if we didn't need cars?
Or what if we had cities where we shrunk
the distances between the places that you need to go?
Like, that would be an expansive way of deconstructing
that solution rather than just taking it as fact.
Exactly.
And so it's a great example,
'cause it's actually one that,
I worked with one of the world's largest auto companies.
So I got introduced to them just a couple years ago.
They're like, we're the first or second.
I won't say this.
Like, a largest automobile company in the world.
And I'm right there, that already told me something
that they see themselves as an auto company,
not as a transportation or a mobility.
So already I could see their kind of official future
was selling more cars over the coming decades.
And so where we got them to was,
well, is your desired future to sell more cars
or is your desired future to still be in business
and growing and helping the world.
And then they're like, oh yeah, it's that,
it's actually that.
And I said, okay, well, if we put this within the context
of increasing urbanization
and kind of where gen Z and Y is going
and where Europe is going,
they're seeing an increasing in these 15 minute cities.
So now you're exam desired future
is to be a relevant mobility provider
in these 15 minute cities.
And the reason the 15 minute cities are so popular is
they allow for more human interaction
that had actually been disaggregated
by the automobile in the suburbs in the first place.
So their examined desired future,
their EDF now is actually in a sense being regenerative
to the issues that they actually helped cause
over the past couple of decades.
Right, right, right.
That's the one thing I talk about in the book is,
you know it's kind of examined if you will,
if you're now being regenerative about it.
You're now actually,
whatever it is that you're doing is making up for,
it doesn't have to even necessarily past trauma,
but things that happened in the past
that took us away from being our best selves,
either as an individual, as a company,
or as a species on this planet.
And to bring it back to telos,
I mean, telos really means to figure out a way
to make your life meaningful beyond yourself.
Like to guard your life with meaning
that is rooted in the past,
but is really about making the world better
for future generations and acting
almost getting to a place where you're intuitively
or instinctually acting altruistically.
Altruistically for the present and for the future.
One of the things that, and I touched on this earlier,
one of the big things that gets in the way of us
thinking long term and acting
on behalf of future generations, is our own death.
It's amazing and Ernest Becker talks about this
kind of the anxiety.
So humans are the only species that we know of
that at a very early point is aware
that it will actually cease to exist biologically.
If you look at most other, my dog Aussie,
I love my dog.
Aussie doesn't sit around there anxious thinking,
God, one day I'm going to die,
I better do X and Y and live in this way.
And Ernest Becker took it much further and he said,
look, the reason we have religion and culture
and everything is just us trying to deal with our own death.
I don't necessarily go that far,
but what I do take away from that,
and it shows up in Longpath is,
it becomes very difficult to think about a moment
past yourself, because to do so requires you
to run up against the wall that is your death.
And so there's some exercises in the book,
and then we do some things at Longpath Labs,
when we do these things called Longpath gather
when we bring people together
that are basically death meditations.
It's a way of kind of taking you out of your own bias
where you can only think up until your own life
and thinking about what comes after.
What we have found, Kimberly Wade Benzon
who works with us, who's a duke,
has an amazing work on legacy.
She mostly works with like CEOs in the business world.
What she's found is, if we can find a way for people
to see that their actions in the moment create legacies
for future generations in a sense that hooks them up,
that puts them in a better place than where they started,
people stop being as afraid of death.
'Cause they see they actually live longer.
So it's a little bit of a secret,
but I'll tell you part of how Longpath was devised
in that sense is in a way
to kind of help us move past our anxiety
and tear towards our own death.
Because when Ari and Rich take actions
that benefit future generations, it could be voting,
it could be consuming, but I will argue in a second
that can also be micro interactions on how we interact
with each other as humans,
that that actually becomes an immortality project.
Right, it gives you like this light dusting
of immortality on your life, right?
Because everything that you're doing
will live on beyond your years.
100%.
Now look, if you're in the development department
at a university, this is your sales pitch.
Except your pitch really is,
give us $100 million and we're gonna put your name
on the side of this building.
You will live forever in this building.
And it's a great way to raise huge gifts
is to connect someone's legacy with a...
They always do it in marble.
I always find it interesting,
the names on the sides of buildings
are the same kind of marble they use for tombstones.
I don't know like it's it.
It's always amazing that we do that.
I never thought of that.
And look, I'm not gonna have hundreds of millions
of dollars to put my name on the side of the building.
But I have three kids, a wife aforementioned Ozzie,
and a whole bunch of people that I interact with,
thousands of people that I interact with.
So how I am going to build a legacy
of making tomorrow better is how I am going to interact
with those people on a moment by moment, day-to-day basis.
That becomes my legacy.
Look, like I said, I have three kids.
So based on some math, two, 300 years from now,
I'm gonna have eight to 9,000 descendants
assuming certain things happen.
That's a lot of people.
Now sometimes when people say that,
they're like, oh, it's genetic.
I'm not talking about genetic,
I'm talking about ways of being.
So I said earlier, in my family we grew up
having dinner together and we talked about things.
We're doing the same thing in my family.
The way I interact with my colleagues,
with the humans that I know,
the way I hopefully interact with Rich Roll,
what that ends up doing is creating a kind of,
and this is complexity theory or chaos theory, many ways,
reverberations that go throughout time,
that becomes my legacy,
not my name on the side of a building.
So that's a Longpath is,
it becomes a kind of immortality project.
Your name's not connected to it,
but your character and your way of being in the world is,
and if we want to kind of set up these hundreds of billions,
if not trillions of humans to come,
we have to start acting like that.
Yeah.
What I love about that is it really recalibrates
our relationship with this idea of legacy.
It's a very expansive definition.
I mean, traditionally we think of legacy
as what are they gonna say about me when I die,
and how much money did I have,
and what are the accomplishments
that are gonna show up in my obid
or is my name gonna be on a building
for the very few people.
But really we all have a legacy
and that is completely detached from accomplishments
or your bank account, or social approval.
Because in every interaction that we have throughout the day
has an impact and there are ripple effects
that go from that.
So to think about legacy not as we're nearing the end
of our professional lives,
but to really embody or to be contemplating legacy,
even as a young person,
I think is a really powerful lever
for how you think about constructing your life
and the avenues for your energy and attention.
Where you put your energy and attention
and how you behave with yourself and with others
are heirlooms in the making.
We often think about heirlooms as furniture or as jewelry,
but there's also emotional heirlooms.
There's these ways of being.
Look, and I've seen how those can be bad.
If we look at a lot of kind of consistent,
terrible systemic traumas that are happening,
domestic abuse at a whole bunch of other things,
all the experts that I've talked to say,
well, anyone who is doing that right now
that happened to them, that happened to them.
And that's at the acute horrific scale.
Now we can flip that and say, well, what does
that look like on the opposite side?
So if we start, I was in the room, a very large room,
with the Dalai Lama once and you can feel that energy.
And I read about Mother Teresa, and Krishnamurti,
and Gandhi and the brilliance of Einstein
and all these folks.
And from things that I've read,
the legacies are about how they were
in the moment with folks.
So now think about, yes, his holiness of Dalai Lama
is an en enlightened one.
But what you can say is very clearly
he has chosen and made a decision
to be love constantly, consistently.
So if we think about how we want other future generations
to live and exist,
not in a kind of mechanistic society
where we see each other in an instrumental way,
these kind of industrial enlightenment ways,
but we wanna see something very different.
How do we choose that?
Because when I talk about in the book is the project.
When I talk about this larger telos,
I talk about human flourishing.
Moving from, I need stuff to a sense of being
and a sense of caring.
But those are the words that I use,
and I do use love, but that's really what it is.
That's what we wanna be, that's what we wanna...
Now, it's very difficult to do.
I write about in the book,
I get these arguments with my wife and my kids
and all these things.
It's kind of like, you see people with these wristbands,
like what would Jesus do?
And it's like, well, what would the Dalai Lama do?
What would the Dalai Lama do?
How would the Dalai Lama reacting be?
That's really what you wanna do,
because as you start doing that,
and we know the science behind this.
We know about adrenaline and cortisol, and dopamine.
And if we wanna start kind of tweaking those,
'cause on the one hand we have Silicon Valley
totally tweaking the levers, right?
Just like ramping up the dopamine and cortisol
and shock da, da.
So we're the change.
The way we interact with others,
it's gonna start shaping the future.
We're the firewall.
Our moment to moment actions are the firewall
from having a world dissolve into one of kind of anger
and bitterness as opposed to kind of one
of human flourishing in love.
So with that though, this idea of telos
and embodying a certain type of sensibility
and orienting your life around something bigger
than yourself, you still have to build into that
this notion of what your horizon looks like, right?
You call it like your Ithaca.
Like what is your Ithaca?
Which begs the question of whether we as a society
or humanity in general has ever had an Ithaca.
So explain that concept.
So this goes back to my time at UC Berkeley
when I was writing my honors thesis
I called it Ithaca lost.
And it was kind of this idea that we had lost
as a society our Ithaca.
So let's go back.
In the Odyssey or thesis--
You have to go way back.
Let's go way, way back.
Odyssey is this maroon and he wants to get back to Ithaca,
he wants to get to his love, his Penelope,
but it's really Ithaca.
But we could argue whether it was Penelope or Ithaca
back to the ruling power, which one it was.
But let's just say it was a kind of Ithaca,
Penelope combination, but we'll stick with Ithaca right now.
And he wanted to get back.
So he went through all these different things,
and the monsters, and the sirens, and all these things.
But it was his goal was to kind of,
his ultimate aim was to return back there.
And so what telo says is would and yes,
Ithaca in a certain sense was a place,
but it's really a kind of state of being back to home,
back to where you belong,
back to something bigger than yourself.
And what I write about in the book is,
and I'm really questioning,
like do we have an Ithaca right now?
I know we had an American dream like a picket fence
and I know there's different...
And I know it's also coming from Western privilege
because when I walk out of here I'll be able
to get into my car and go buy food.
So on a Maslowian sense,
kind of the first two steps on that pyramid to say
to even have this conversation of a larger Ithaca
for homo sapiens, first and foremost,
we have to bring everyone up to a certain level.
Let's start there.
This is kind of the Bucky thing
that you talked about earlier.
But then within that,
and I would argue that without this larger Ithaca,
we won't even be able to get to that.
Where is it that we wanna get to
as a species on planet earth?
'Cause right now, look, this is one of the things...
So the treaty of west Follia that ended the 100 years war,
created the nation state about 400 years old.
So that's another thing that we kind of dissolved
at the end of this intertidals,
even the idea of a nation state and borders.
So putting the nation state aside
and just saying as a species on the planet
regardless of whether or not there's kind of nation states
involved in this part of the conversation,
what do we want it to look like two, 3000 years from now?
Because like, here's the thing.
So I've seen a bunch of movies from like Roman gladiators
and I went to go visit the Coliseum once
with my family.
And it was amazing and it seemed like so long ago.
But here's the thing, the year 4,020 A.D,
which seems like so...
Like think about most of the science fiction we see
none of it goes out to the year 4,000.
But the year 4,020 A.D,
we're closer to that than we are to the Coliseum
in Roman times.
So even though what I'm,
sounds like what I'm talking about is really out there.
It really isn't.
We're literally kind of flipping
the lever over on history.
So if we want to get to that,
we have to have a real honest conversation about where it is
that we want to go to,
not just cause we need to have the conversation,
but because what I alluded to earlier
that without having that conversation,
that emotional connection of what
that protopia could look like.
So it's not dystopia, it's not utopia,
which means no place, but protopia,
a term Kevin Kelly came up with,
which is a tomorrow better than today.
If we want these protopia in 4,020 A.D if not sooner,
my argument is without that vision of what that looks like,
what that land of milk and honey looks like.
Remember, well, I won't say we are.
I won't bring you into my story.
But when we, the Hebrews were slaves and we left Egypt
and we didn't wanna go further
or say no, Moses, we can't go further,
he came back and said,
no, no, there's a land of milk and honey.
Here's a vision of a place, a way of being.
And I know that's nothing metaphor,
but man, there was some good marketing in that.
Because without that land of milk and honey,
without that Ithaca,
it's gonna be very difficult to move us
as a species through, not just this intertidal,
but then to do the hard work
that we have to do to get to a place
that looks very different than where we are today.
That gets us to the place that you brought up earlier.
This kind of Buckminste Fuller feed, cloth, educate,
and take care of everyone on the planet.
We need that vision if we wanna get to there.
Sure.
There's no chance that we're gonna arrive at that type
of a future without some architecting around it
from very smart people.
And I know your organization does this.
There's other organizations that are doing it,
but it doesn't feel like it's occurring on a mass scale.
And what I see, and I'm interested in your perspective
on this is sort of in place of that
considered architecting around the future
that we want to inhabit, we're seeing this future
that's sort of being dictated by Silicon Valley.
This techno monk ideology that the future
that we want and that we're aiming towards
and that is inevitable because of our
sort of built in desire to continually innovate
is this transhumanism.
Like this idea that we're gonna merge technology
with humanity, that technology holds the answers
to all the problems that ail us
and we shouldn't really worry
about these existential threats
because we've always innovated our way out of it.
And in this model I feel like we're just being reactive
and we're kind of blindly innovating forward,
but there isn't like a sort of master plan
as to why we're doing this.
And my kind of lens onto this comes mostly
through what's happening in health span
and longevity science.
And look, I had Peter D Amanda here,
who's all these like singularity university folks
who who are sort of Pollyanna
and overly optimistic about where we're headed
with all of this.
But my problem with this,
and I've pointed this out to these individuals
who have sat across from me is
that what I don't see is an honest reckoning
with the moral and ethical implications
of these technological advances.
They're sort of acknowledged in passing,
but kind of also dismissed without,
what I feel to be a responsible consideration.
And I heard you talk about the difference
between Moore's law and the innovation of the chip
and computing power,
but what's lacking is any kind of Moore's law
with respect to how we're maturing
from a moral unethical perspective.
Yeah, I mean, look, so I came over agent.com 1.0
and lived in the Bay Area.
And so Moore's law was kind of like, we live by Moore's law.
So I think of the hundreds of millions,
if not billions of dollars
that have gone into kind of ensuring Moore's law
that a chip speeds go faster over time
and size of the chip get smaller.
And I think, God, what if hundreds of millions
if not billions of dollars went into kind of evolving
our moral codes and our ways of being
with each other in the world.
And look, this is an obvious...
What we're seeing and all of your guests are amazing,
but what--
(Rich laughing)
That's okay. Go ahead.
I also know they control the servers,
so if I were, it'll be gone and it would be like--
All is safe here.
It'll be like the avenger.
We're in a protected room.
It'll be be like a snap in the--
Just imagine this Buckminster Fuller Geodesic Domes.
Yeah, it's its own own fair day.
Do you have fair day cage?
Yeah, but do you have your own cloud servers?
Because I know with that,
then all of a sudden we disappear.
There is a desire among a certain group of individuals
to move as quickly as possible
through the biological instance that is a homo sapien
towards something that doesn't have pain, or worry,
or death.
I totally get that and I understand that.
And how much of that is being driven
by a profound fear of death
that we were talking about earlier.
100% of it is by that.
And so again, 'cause I'm trying to answer the question
without going after anyone.
So we'll talk about this in the aggregates
or if you will, if folks.
So have you been to Japan?
No.
Okay.
On the list.
So it was...
The first time I went to Japan I was there
for a couple of weeks and I spent time in Kyoto
and on this thing called the Philosopher's Walk.
And this was right after our twin daughters were born.
And something that's just jumped out at me
and you'll see where I'm going with this
is that a number of the people that were there,
their gardeners or monks, mostly monks
who were walking around were very okay showing their age.
There was lots of like gray around,
which may not seem like a big deal.
But from that trip, I landed back at San Francisco
and I went to a bunch of stuff in Silicon Valley.
And I noticed there was like no gray,
even on people that should have gray.
Like this idea...
So in Japan, we look at being older
and moving through these arcs in life,
Chip Connelly talks about this,
Seabrooks is talking about this other,
other folks are talking about.
'Cause like, what does it mean to age and become wise
and think about our legacies?
It's like there's that
and then there's a kind of certain subset of folks
who like don't want to die
and are stuck in the kind of perpetual present.
And this is my question too,
I don't know what it is that they're waiting for.
What do you think it is that they want to stick around for?
Look, don't get me wrong, I don't wanna die anytime soon,
but I recognize like without death
there is no meaning in life.
To live forever means you don't pass gifts,
you don't cherish the moments that you're in.
Yeah, the philosophical discussion around,
what would it actually feel like to double our lifespan,
I think is not being adequately wrestled with.
And look, it's human nature.
I like living, I wanna live as long as I want to,
so there's nothing implicitly wrong or bad about that.
And I think that gets matched with how kind of sexy
and exciting it is about breakthroughs
in science and technology that could actually
sort of solve a problem
that historically we've never been able to solve.
And that's enthralling.
So the extent to which each of these players
or individuals are being propelled
by some kind of unhealthy relationship with death is,
I don't know, I'm not a psychologist
and I don't know these people that well either,
but certainly it comes into play.
But I think you're right.
Like the extent to which we feel our lives have direction
and meaning, and purpose, and fulfillment
is inextricably wired to the choices
that we make every single day and the implications
of those choices in terms of how it's benefiting others.
I mean, the science, the philosophy, faith, traditions,
all of these things demonstrate that this is true.
Yes, we'd like to extend the term of life,
but there has to be an endpoint
or it drains all of its meaning.
Exactly.
And that becomes a question is,
this is a quantity over quality in some senses.
And then where I come at it in terms of Longpath
is thinking look, whether I live to 80 or 150,
what's more important is how I'm showing up every day
for those around me because that's my legacy,
not like that, not that.
And I'd like to be around, and don't get me wrong,
I'd love to live to 150 healthy, 150.
But what's more important to me is how I am
with every human or non-living thing for that matter
interacting in the moment to moment,
because it gives meaning to my day to day,
but it also allows me to live in such a way
that I know I'm doing what I can at least for our species
over the next several thousand years,
over the next hundreds of billions, if not trillions of us
that we are setting up every generation successfully
to live a better more flourishing, psychologically,
mentally spiritual life than what we came into.
That to me becomes...
So if we took this kind of...
And by that's Silicon Valley.
So like every generation the computer just will get better
and better and faster and faster.
What if we took that same mentality
to kind of our moral code as opposed
to just our software code.
Is if we said to ourselves,
every generation of humans will be morally better,
will be happier, will have more purpose
and more flourishing, that is our telos.
Yeah, I mean, that's the bigger point
that I wanted to make.
It's not necessarily about longevity science,
it's really about the importance of building
that back into how we're thinking about
and crafting our culture and our future,
because we don't see that right now.
And as you kind of trace in the book when you look
at the antecedence for kind of our cultural values,
you can trace them back to the Stoics and the age of reason,
enlightenment and all of that.
All of which have lots of great things to say
about how to live, but contemplate it only in the context
of one lifetime.
And really for the most part do it at the expense
of our kind of emotional and spiritual lives.
And I feel like, given the fact that we're
in this intertidal moment,
the solution lies in a revolution of consciousness.
Like short of really elevating our moral and conscious game,
we're not gonna be able to solve these problems.
We can future cast and do all the other stuff,
but we really need to elevate the manner
in which we're thinking about ourselves
and our responsibility to humanity and future generations
in a really material way.
That seems to be the thing that has to come first.
I mean, so what you just laid out is
why I wrote this book, right?
Because we're at a moment where when
if we think about consciousness,
we're at for the first time contrary to every other...
By the way, there'll be other intertidals, I'm sure.
But this is the first intertidal where we are actually aware
that we are in it while it's happening.
And so what we can do is,
we can kind of let the wind take us wherever it wants,
or we can be conscious about the evolution of consciousness
in this moment to help see us through.
And so the Longpath mindset isn't saying,
well, do this and consciousness will evolve.
What I'm saying is,
this is a priority of conscious evolution
is thinking in a completely different way.
Moving from a way where you only look at the world
through your own lifespan to one that goes beyond yours
and one that came before yours
that puts you into a larger context.
So you talked about the dome earlier.
You were saying,
so Buckminster Fuller created geodesic dome.
And the way geodesic dome works is,
or they're amazing if you've ever been in actual a tent
like one or you played it on monkey bars is,
all the triangles are in like 10 (indistinct),
they're in tangent with each other.
And so Longpath as a mindset only get about two thirds
of the way there in terms of really kind of
it manifesting in your life if you're doing it alone.
So you said earlier kind of like we have
to co-create these futures.
We have to kind of co-create our Longpath.
Our links in the chain have to start coming together
with those in this current moment.
So it's no longer just empathy with future generations
and with the past and with our own present,
but with those around us,
and we start carrying the load together.
So if we wanna just take individual actions
for a better tomorrow,
it's like Lincoln logs, like one on top of the other.
And the one below just holds the way or the other.
But if we're in this kind of dynamic tension,
and what the dynamic tension means,
and this kind of geodesic dome metaphor is,
and this goes to your idea about different examined,
desired futures is, we're not gonna agree on all of them.
You and I may have very different ideas
about the examined desired future for ourselves
as individuals or even for our society, that's okay
as long as we're having the conversation.
Right now we're not even having that conversation.
We've kind of gone to our different corners
and it's like a battle to the end.
It's a battle to the death about what are the vision.
I firmly believe that a lot of the kind of political discord
that we're going through in this country,
if not the world right now,
isn't about today,
it's about different competing visions of tomorrow.
But we haven't actually kind of elucidated what those are.
So I said, we have these weird proxy battles today.
But what we're really saying is,
how do we wanna be over the next several centuries,
if not millennia?
And this gets into questions of religion
and the impact of religion on deciding that
and the four horsemen and all this other stuff.
But that's a conversation I'd like to see.
I'd love to see people on the Senate floor
instead of battling over this or that text of a bill saying,
Hey, let's talk about where we see ourselves
in 500 years as a country.
Yeah, and why don't we have a Silicon Valley
for that kind of Teleology?
Why don't we have a Manhattan project around
how we're crafting the future
and how we're grappling with our moral compass?
I mean, one of the suggestions you make,
which I love is this idea of a US department of the future
with a budget that equals the Defense Department budget.
Yeah, exactly.
Like if we really want to take out an insurance policy
on our future, we have to be considering these things
and not just blindly kind of rolling forward
and seeing what happens.
And that what....
Right now the future is washing over us
as opposed to us thinking of the future as a verb
and it's something that we actually create
and do in an applied way.
And so it's just that the Department of Defense in the US
is highly reactive.
The state department, we have USAID which I've worked with,
who actually does some really good work
in developing countries.
But now what we need is this department of the future
whose sole kind of task is,
not to figure out well, do we invest in crypto, or 5G,
or whatever, but to actually say,
okay, it's 2022, in 2122 or in 2222,
where do we want to be?
How are we going to measure if we're going to be successful?
Right now by the way, the way countries measure success
is by GDP, gross domestic product.
So what that actually means though is,
if I sell you cigarettes, and God forbid you get cancer,
and I treat you, the GDP goes up.
I sold you cigarettes and all your chemo and all that,
The metrics are all and it goes back to incentives.
And the incentives are all gone.
Whereas the department of future would say,
okay, we can look at what Bhutan does,
grows happiness product,
but I know there's issues there.
Sure.
But we can rethink of the incentives and say,
well, okay, it's not about how many people are in prison,
how many people are not in prison?
Like a metric that I would love to see is,
how do we close 99% of the prisons in this country?
Just how do we do it?
'Cause when I brought that up to people,
they're like, that's crazy, that'll never happen
because people always commit crimes.
I said, well, why are they committing those crimes?
Like where did that come from?
And there's different ways to think of human nature.
Well, there will always be criminal,
there'll always be that, that'll always happen.
If that's how you think,
we're not gonna get very far in the conversation.
But if we start to go back and say,
and by the way, this goes back to our conversation
about reconstruction and slavery in America.
If we wanna close 99% of prisons in America,
we have to go back a few hundred years.
And actually think about what got us to these points,
the projects, reconstruction, post World War II,
the internal migrations.
How we did and didn't handle those things properly,
mostly very much improperly.
And then starts saying,
well, instead of maybe building fewer prisons,
let's think about how we invest in schools
or in communities and take those dollars.
I was asked to be part of a group in the US government
that thinks about the futures across different agencies.
And the guy who invited me was actually the futurist
for the Bureau of Prisons.
Like why does Bureau of Prisons have a futurist?
And he's like, well, it takes 10, 15 years
to find the land and build a prison.
So we're looking at demographics and economics,
and that's how we're planning.
So they're planning on how many prisons to build
based on what's happening now kinda pre cogging,
kind of big data to see what they should build.
And you're thinking exactly what I thought.
Well, if you know all those things,
unemployment, and families, and this and that
are going to lead to that,
why don't we work at those root cause issues
and not build them?
Doesn't drive GDP.
It doesn't drive GDP yet.
The incentives aren't there yet.
I mean, we are seeing certain bonds
that are being kind of created.
They're trying this in Boston where not for profits
will actually get money if people don't go back to jail.
It's kind of these like anti recidivism bonds
where it's like, well, we'll pay you $50,000
if this guy who's about to get out,
doesn't offend again in the next five years.
And that's how they get actually their budget.
So we kind of see new incentive systems coming,
but this needs to be at a much larger level.
One of the other things I put in the book is this idea
that it's very simple.
I talked to somebody who's an architect.
He said, it wouldn't be that hard,
is to literally take out one of the walls,
either on the Senate or on the house side in the US Congress
and replace it with a big, like 10 by 20 foot window.
And on the other side of that window would be soundproof,
would be in nursery for kids.
It could be people related to the members of Congress
or in the community.
And the reason I wanna see that happen,
it's an idea...
Because think about it when you are in--
Are you gonna behave that badly
when there's kids watching.
It's most about behaving,
but it's about recognizing that the bills that you are
passing is in that other room.
More often, look at the age of most of our leadership
in their 70s and 80s, which is great and amazing,
but they're not gonna be around for a lot of this stuff
that my kids are gonna be around for.
I would love to see my kids and babies on the other side
of the wall of Congress so when they're passing,
or not as it is right now, not passing legislation,
they see who's gonna directly impact.
Right.
The pessimist in me, my brain immediately goes
to campaign finance problems and the election cycle.
And it's like, yeah, you can put the window in there
in the nursery but until you deconstruct the mechanisms
that are driving the decisions that are antithetical
to the best interest of future generations,
we're not getting out of the gate.
Yeah, so yes, we need ranked choice of voting.
We need to rethink gerrymandering and take it
into a non-partisan or even like computers,
all those things.
My argument would be that for us to actually start,
one way for us to start enacting those systemic changes
that we need to see is by giving people a vision
of a future that we want.
We wanna see...
Well, here's what a functioning, this is the TV show
that we're doing.
This is what a functioning democracy looks like.
This is what a functioning education system,
a functioning criminal justice,
this is what it could look like
as opposed to the wire
or as opposed to all these things that we see,
it could actually look like this.
So in your kind of day job at running Longpath Labs,
you go into government organizations, corporations,
you mentioned this auto manufacturer,
I'm sure you have tons of NDAs
and you can't talk about anything specifically,
although it would be great to be a fly on the wall,
I'm sure there's been some amazing experiences.
How receptive do you find these clients to these notions?
Like, are they really thinking in a Longpath way?
Are they just thinking about like,
Hey, by next year I've gotta get my numbers up
or, what does that look like?
The practicalities of trying to get people's minds
to bend around these concepts.
Yeah, a lot of NDAs.
Here's what I can tell you,
what I've learned, which is not what I thought
was gonna be the case is,
the folks that are the most receptive to this
tend to be on the tail end of their careers.
So I thought it'd be like the younger folk.
Like, yes, I'm 35 year old vice president,
I'm in this meeting with this futurist Ari Wallach
at Longpath, let's do this.
They're the ones who are like, whoa, this is, whoa too much.
We can't reconfigure our business.
I just bought a house, a 30 year fixed mortgage.
Like they're not...
Which is always the way.
I always thought it would be something very different.
Whereas the people who are now thinking
about their legacies, so it's like people
in their 50s or 60s are like, okay, here's what we did.
Maybe we could have done this slightly better.
How do we start to kind of rethink this?
What is going to be my legacy?
What am I going to pass on to future generations?
How am I going to be seen as a great ancestor?
So this book just came out by Jack Welch.
So all these people celebrated Jack Welch
while he was doing what he was doing.
And now people are starting to look back and say,
oh my God, this is what destroyed America,
this form of capitalism.
Those pendulums tend to swing.
They tend to swing.
And so I find myself in these rooms with these folks
who are open to the ideas.
What we have found is more often than not,
and this will not surprise you,
is one of the first things I get these senior leaders to do,
be it in government or in finance,
family offices or corporate is,
we have a very long conversation
obviously about their legacy.
So we emotionally connect them to the work
and what they're doing.
But then we say, okay, let's create a vision,
examine desired future
that you wanna see for your organization.
That and this is the important part
that is after you are gone.
Now you are gone could be after your death
or after you're retired and you moved to Boca Raton,
but you are no longer here.
So you're either looking back up from the clouds of heaven
or from your whatever.
What does that vision look like?
And you would think that'd be a very quick,
that's the longest part of the process
because it's the desired future,
we can usually get to pretty quickly.
The examined requires them to go back into the past,
to think about how they got there as an organization,
as a government agency.
Even if we think about kind of national security
or we work with police and stuff,
police came from slave patrol.
Like thinking about all of these deep past inheritances,
play a role in how we shape
and create these examined desired futures.
Sometimes we have to go through some kind of choppy water
to get there.
But more often not reckoning and reconciling
with the past opens the aperture about
what tomorrow's could be in a way that is important
to them and their organizations.
And then to your main question,
that vision becomes a catch anchor
that can pull them through.
So you know how cage works?
A cage is an anchor on a ship.
You kind of swirl and you throw it,
in this case you throw it 20 feet,
it's sinks, it's connected to a rope
and then you pull yourself to where the anchor is.
So these visions become a cage to allow you
to pull the organization.
Look, frogs won't leave if they don't see the lily pad,
humans won't move if they don't see
what they're moving towards.
And the work that we do super important to figure out
what that vision is,
what that both examine desired future is.
And then wrap that within that telos.
what is the ultimate aim.
More often than not, we always come back to
that being around flourishing.
Being in a place of care and of being
and ultimately of love.
Yeah.
And that sort of altruistic, empathetic aspect
to the whole thing is kind of like the high minded driver,
but it's also anchored.
The legacy piece feels to me more like the thing
that activates self-interest.
And your receptivity or your kind of consideration
of legacy tends to happen near the end of the career
because you start to fear death
and you're pondering your mortality.
So the trick becomes, how do you get young people
to start thinking about legacy earlier?
And how do you create an environment where altruism
and empathy, and all these things
that we've talked about become core values
and drivers of decision making?
Yeah, so I was saying earlier right before COVID hit,
we were experimenting with this,
we were doing these things called Longpath gathers.
And we were--
Kind of like WeWorks.
We were doing...
Yeah, We were like in couple dozen WeWorks on
the East Coast, that's a whole other story.
But a couple dozen WeWorks on the East Coast
and we were bringing specifically kind of
young entrepreneurs into these sessions
that would be 60 minutes.
And it was a combination of the exercises
that you see in the book also with guided meditations
and kind of mindfulness training and journaling,
kind of all the different ways we think
about our stories and what got us there.
And what we were finding is that folks become more receptive
to thinking about their legacy
when they think no surprise about the legacies
that they have inherited.
So if you say, well, what do you want your legacy
to be several generations out from now?
People are like, I don't know, I'm like 32 years old
and I just raise my A round, like leave me alone.
So Yaacov Trope, NYU said,
you never start bringing people in the future,
you always have to go back.
And then from there,
because the way the hippocampus works
and the way the brain works is,
once you've activated them along a continuum
from the past, which they know very well,
they're more likely to be able to think about
the future in a constructive way.
And so that's what we started doing.
And we started to look right up the go,
we started seeing some really interesting traction.
People starting to say, you know what?
Like I...
So we'd have these conversation,
and this is just maybe a silly example.
But then folks would be like,
well, what is a B Corp?
Like, what does that mean to actually be
a public benefit corporation?
And they started having these larger because,
look, ultimately we all want a sense of kind of purpose
and meaning.
Like, to what end for our own life and for hundreds,
if not thousands of years,
to what end was given to us by God,
religion but God in general?
As the fastest green cohort in the US
when you ask people that question on pew,
they don't say any specific religion, they say spiritual,
but not religious.
So there's a God shaped hole in almost all of us,
not size but shaped hole
that can only be filled by something.
And this is, I said this a lot earlier,
the enlightenment kind of killed God in that way,
it took the mystery of it out.
And so how do we fill that God shaped hole with something
that is non ideological, non-dogmatic,
and just basically not terrible?
The closest thing that I being able to come up with
to fill in that kind of God shaped hole,
because God it was an audience that you played to,
because after you died,
God then decided what happened to you.
So you're always kind of doing the good thing
to play to that.
What's in Longpath, what I think can help fill that hole,
and I don't mean this necessarily at a psychological
or spiritual level, is future generations.
Our generations, the hundreds of millions, billions,
and trillions that will come will be kind of looking back.
You are playing to them,
your legacy and your actions and your behaviors.
Why you do good stuff, what your purpose is
is to ensure that they have a flourishing reality.
That I think is one way that we can fill that.
So when we would talk to these younger folks
at Longpath gathers, that would be the conversation.
You are doing this product
or whatever it is that you're developing.
Yes, you need it now but I'll be honest,
a lot of folks would come outta some of these and be like,
oh, that's a crappy idea.
That thing I'm working on isn't,
that's not hooking up 2122.
This is just...
Like we had a, I can't say it, we had an engagement
with a major social media platform
asking them all these questions and doing all of this.
Within two or three months of our kind of engagement
on this, almost the entire team had quit,
which is not what you wanna bring us in for.
But because we were asking those questions.
I'll lead to you to think about it.
But they were like--
You just shake the tree a little bit.
Yeah, we're just like-
Shake the car up tree.
Yeah, shake the car up tree.
I mean, look, exactly.
Look, the book starts off with the story of Hony.
So Hony is walking down a path one day,
this is the story from the Tomo.
Hony is walking down
and he sees this older man planting a carob tree.
And carob trees is, and he says, he goes,
why are you planting this carob tree?
You're an old man.
And how long does it take for this carob tree
to have fruit and leaves and become trees?
He's like, oh, 30 or 40 years.
He goes, well, why are you planting it then?
You'll be long gone.
And the man answers him very simply,
when I was young I played in the shade of carob trees,
I ate from the fruit of Carob trees,
someone planted this for me to be in,
therefore I will plant it for the next generation.
And so if you distill Longpath down to like a sentence,
is what you are doing planting a Carob tree or not.
Are you doing something for the next generation or not?
And here's the thing, and to your earlier point,
it's not totally selfless.
There's a lot of self-interest in that.
That's the beauty of it.
When you plant something for future gen, you feel good.
There's no greater...
I can tell you this,
'cause this is what I do with my day job.
No greater kind of oxytocin would dump in your brain
than doing things that you know are gonna hook
future generations up.
It's just because you start to have a sense of comradery
and connection to the universe that goes beyond the ego
that goes beyond just your own life.
Because not only does it obviously take you forward,
but you realize someone had done this for you,
so it also takes you backwards.
So it's this immortality project that isn't just
about you living forever,
but you start to actually realize you're part of something
that's been around before you and will be here after you,
and there's no greater feeling.
What I love about that is that it's wired such
that even if your motivations are entirely selfish,
it still works.
Like let's say, I don't give a shit about life,
future, whatever, I just know I'm gonna feel better
if I do right by future generations
and then you feel better
and then ultimately you will come to,
it's like an act as if thing,
you will come to inhabit that sensibility.
And then look, incentives,
like at the end of the day, we are highly,
highly evolved primates.
So there's certain things that are wiring
that we have to work to.
I'm full of hope enough for who and what we can become,
but I'm not blinded to what we are.
My dad informed me of that every night at a dinner table,
don't forget.
Look, he inscribed for my bar Mitzva
where he gave me like a siddur door, like a prayer book
and he wrote in Yiddish,
which I had to get translated
after he passed away from someone.
And what it basically said was,
never forget what the Nazis did to your family.
And that's heavy, super heavy.
But it was him saying, be realistic,
do the work that you have to do,
but be realistic with what you have
and then move it forward.
My friends, do you know Scott Harrison from charity water?
Yeah.
He always says, don't fear work that has no end.
Certainly Longpath is work that does not have an end,
but the pursuit of it gives you meaning in all the ways
that we've discussed today.
And I think maybe a good way to kind of end this
is with some thoughts about how you think about work
that has no end.
And as somebody who's devoted to this journey,
how is it that we're gonna get to scale this
so that we can solve problems in a truly meaningful way
that will craft the future that that we're aiming for.
Look, to your earlier point,
like there isn't a $3 billion empathy fund right now.
But there are philanthropists, and foundations,
and teachers, and parents, and folks
that are starting to understand
that if we're going to make it
we have to start cultivating this skill.
Empathy is on a fixed trait.
Empathy is a muscle, it can be learned.
You can actually, and Jamel Zack at Stanford
has shown this,
that people when asked to kind of empathize
with other individuals, especially if there's dollars
put to it will do extremely well.
You won't be surprised that it was men who did this.
It's like, how do you think these people are feeling?
They're like, I don't know.
It's like, I'll give you five bucks, you get it right,
they're like, ah, they're feeling like this.
So it's something that, but it's also innate in us
'cause it helped us from the Serengeti to today.
If we are to make it, which I profoundly think we are,
we have to start finding the people who are doing the work
that is making the world better
for us here today and for future generations.
Yeah, yes.
Buy the book, read the book, talk about it.
Someone told me the other day,
they're like, well, how you feel if people read your book
and start doing the Longpath mindset
but don't actually refer to it as Longpath?
I was like, great, even better.
I don't need it.
The book is already, so it's done.
So whether it's through that,
or however you find a, to be honest,
some sort of practice that makes you be your best self,
not just for you, but because becoming your best self
is actually is how you best pass
that baton in the transition zone
that we are in right now.
And so what it looks like is scale
is having that vision for the world that you want
and sharing that, facilitating that.
One of the things that we do
when we go into organizations immediately next to
whoever the grand PBA is,
there's always someone sitting to the right of them.
I say, hey, can you get outta that chair?
And they, okay.
And they think I'm gonna sit there.
I go, no, no, no.
That chair, leave that chair empty.
That chair represents future generations.
So in every decision that you make in here,
be it auto or government, look to that chair.
Always look to that empty chair and say,
are we doing right by them?
Isn't that a twist on the Bezos thing
of leaving the empty chair for the customer?
Yeah.
So in this sense, the customer are future generations.
And what we've seen is, even something small like that,
leaving that chair open or...
In my home like most people's homes,
we have photos of all of our kids up in our armoire.
And there's photos of my parents,
and my grandparents, and myself, my wife, and our children.
And I've said aside, people think it's crazy,
but that's okay.
There's an empty frame.
And no pressure on my kids to have kids.
But the empty frame is for like another generation to come.
And so when I'm making decisions,
and I don't mean like big profound decisions,
I mean, sometimes just in terms of like
how I'm interacting with my kids,
and I catch that empty frame,
it's the Longpath single.
Longpath started as a mantra, just as a word.
I was getting into it with my son the other day
and my wife was there.
And anyone who has a wife like mine knows
that the end of the day they're the ones
who keep it going in that way.
And I was kind of going at my son with this thing
and she's looked at me and she goes Longpath.
She has to remind you, it's hilarious.
Yeah, I mean, the book has a bunch of examples
of that as well.
I was like, yeah, like, why am I doing this?
Like what am I setting up?
And so I have hope that this scales as people,
you have an amazing listenership
as people kind of by the book or not.
But then as you kind of think about that,
these things reverberate,
they start to kind of trim tab out.
Our smaller interactions make those things happen.
And they scale when we do it together,
when we facilitate things with open chairs,
when we share our vision, when we change our behaviors,
and when we kind of cultivate our mind
in a way to act healthier around individuals.
And how we react to things,
that's how we overcome short-termism
and how we build better futures for all.
There's something really empowering about that.
Like you have a sense of agency.
Like your actions will reverberate into future generations
regardless of the quality of those actions.
So to take stock of those actions
and understand that they are meaningful,
even if you're feeling disempowered in your life,
I think is a very cool notion
or just kind of sensibility to inhabit.
Yep. 100%.
Yeah, well, it was good talking to you, man.
I really enjoyed that.
The book is "Longpath".
I really dug the book,
I think everybody should check it out.
And we did it, man.
How do you feel?
I feel great.
Thanks for having me.
Anywhere else you wanna direct people
who wanna learn more about what you're up to?
Oh, well, longpath.org.
And then from there you can see all sorts of stuff.
You can learn about the book,
about Longpath (indistinct) you can sign up for things.
And obviously on Instagram, Ari W.
But really go to longpath.org, sign up for the newsletter.
If you wanna get involved,
we're doing more things kind of in person now
as we start to get outta this thing.
Whether it's Longpath, gather in-person,
we're doing in different cities or digitally,
love to have any, especially anyone who is already
kind of a ritual listener and viewer
already has kind of made the cut and at my book
in terms of someone who wants to do this
and is already kind of starting to do this work,
we would just love to level it up with them.
Yeah, very cool.
I'll link all that stuff up in the show notes, of course.
And also your Ted Talk, like all this stuff there
for people to check out.
And that's it, man.
That was super fun.
Thanks.
Yeah, feel good?
Feels great.
Awesome.
Talk to you soon.
Peace.
(upbeat music)